I'll or podcast tea icgn that content
work and yeah with this fine gentleman
here
it's your name sir solomon Romney
awesome now what's your role as far as
in reference to the adaptive controller
so I have I'm a user I am design
consultant and I'm a spokesperson design
consultant now one thing I feel that
Microsoft doesn't get enough credit with
something like this is that it's
something that's never really been
addressed in the community and it's such
a need so um can you tell us about the
whole inspiration was on the process and
the design absolutely so this started
three years ago as a hackathon project
Microsoft every july has a major hack
it's the largest new world where the
Guinness Book of World Records for it
Wow yeah last year there were 12,000
people doing our hack awesome and so
back in 15 a group called war fighters
engaged which helps disabled veterans in
the US awesome game yeah they came to us
and they said we really like to do some
more ok and because these are guys who
and they're one among many different
organizations like AbleGamers special
effect in the UK and folks like that who
traditionally crack open our controllers
and build custom rigs out of it gosh who
said they generally do that themselves
ok a lot of hearing I'm a lot of hard
work and they said we want something
better and we said absolutely ok so
three years ago that started as a hack
project it's evolved a lot it's gone
through multiple other hacks since then
- and then finally to full production
and development and it's been a huge
passion project for Microsoft for Xbox
for anyone and everyone who's ever had
any contact with it it's something that
we believe in very firmly it looks it
looks fantastic yeah yeah let's go to
break down the decide elope ok so what
we have here on the front you have
everything you will need out of box to
be able to navigate through the system
ok so you've got an over sized
directional pad essentially concave to
make all this year to hit you've got
convex large buttons near a and B okay
that are easy to hit whether you're on
the edge or in the center you get the
same pleasure there's lots of time
awesome your
Nexxus button your menus and all that
even your profile button here okay which
allows you to set up different digital
profiles so as you're changing games or
changing users okay with a click of a
button up and ready to go okay so that's
all along here the front and then the
real magic happens here on this path
okay so this is where all of the digital
ports are so what's happened is we've
taken every button on a traditional
standard control see them always in the
maps yep nicely from left to right like
you would on a regular keyboard set up
with a 3.5 millimeter jack port right
and the reason we chose that is because
that is the industry standard for
adaptive switches so for a lot of using
this they already have their I have the
paucity I was just straight through
exaction so really all you do is get to
whichever button you need they're
cracking up in a controller and doing
all of that work plug and play that is
awesome underrated is plug and play you
know as far as customers ability it's
just straight through now you know you
don't have to like configure each
specific game I'm assuming right you
can't know if you want to really know
profiles come both lot of mobility then
we design specific for limited mobility
but we've extended it out to many other
uses but especially who may or may not
be avid gamers right be able to go for
someone if they happy to remove this
from Extang and then use it in
construction and that's a special
training or anything like both worlds
you said that the intake of to and up
so the response how people been taking
overwhelmingly positive people I mean
I'm a user I love it
the stories that I hear from people
about how to change their life how
they're gonna be able to play games
they've never been able to play or go
back to playing games they used to play
mister this is going to or the life of
someone I know I have a friend this way
number and things and now we can game
and we got game together exactly it's
just huge this is also another thing
that actually interesting is that Xbox
is teasing the only show controllers
like this is the controller that is
amazing that needs to be shown it they
don't get enough as a proper shine or
tail what do we look 9999 us pre-orders
start today part pre-orders today
release date the release no baby fall
the Xbox controller man this thing looks
fantastic no function that doing it does
it doesn't need to you know not
emphasize enough that's how great this
thing awesome pleasure thank you so much
site and in the physical Microsoft
stores ok cool live near one of those go
in and see them they already has our
people to yeah